Pulitzer prize-winning journalist Fred
Kaplan outlines the government's plan to
combat cyber attacks that's a look at
some of the current nonfiction
bestsellers according to politics and
prose bookstore in Washington DC
many of these authors have or will be
appearing on book TV you can watch them
on our website book TV org
on Sunday April 3rd book TV is live with
author and publisher of Forbes magazine
Steve Forbes on in-depth our live
monthly call-in show mr. Forbes has
authored many books which focus on
politics and economics in his most
recent book reviving America he argues
for a replacement of the current tax
code and a repeal of the Affordable Care
Act other recent titles include power
ambition glory which compares great
leaders of the ancient world with modern
business leaders and how capitalism will
save us why free people and free markets
are the best answer in today's economy
in 2014 mr Forbes appeared on book TV
discussing his book money the topic of
money is very straightforward and simple
even though it's shrouded in a lot of
jargon a lot of equations the the idea
of money is very basic we've gotten away
from it and our policymakers today know
less about money monetary policy than
they did a hundred years ago and since
the early 1970s even though he had
booming decades in the 80s and 90s
overall our growth rates since we went
off the Bretton Woods system the old
gold standard in 1971 the US average
growth rates are less than they were
before 1971 and if we'd maintained the
growth rates that we had for 180 years
up to 1971 if we'd maintained those
growth rates after 1971 on average the
US economy today would be 50% larger
than it is now
Steve Forbes live on book TV's in-depth
Sunday April 3rd noon to 3:00 p.m.
Eastern
next on book TV James Walsh uncovers the
world of union organizing in his book
playing against the house
now on to tonight's festivities we have
James Walsh here of course he is the
author of playing against the house
the dramatic world of an undercover
union organizer in the book was recently
released and it has received some some
glowing reviews to date James's work has
appeared on the websites of The New
Yorker Esquire and GlobalPost and he's
on the editorial staff of New York
magazine so without further ado please
give James a warm welcome hello thank
you to everyone for coming I remember in
the summer of 2007 I had one of those
great unpaid editorial internships at a
magazine near here
national now defunct National Geographic
adventure magazine and that was the
first time I heard about the half King
and I remember just being dumbstruck to
think that somebody could both be a
journalist and own a bar and Here I am
and during that same summer I also got
to deliver a package to Sebastian
hunger's house so for those of you don't
know he's the philippic journalist who
also happens to own view or one of the
owners of this bar and another thing
happened that summer that was the first
time somebody handed me a Ted Conover
book and it was the book New Jack which
was about Ted's year spent as a prison
guard at sing-sing and that was the
first book that really got me interested
in experiential journalism
some undercover some not and I have
since read all of his books and a few
years later I had a job interview with a
historian and who at the end of the
interview asked me to pitch him a story
and I had heard about friends who were
working at hotels I did graduated from
pretty good schools colleges and working
at hotels to organize unions from the
inside and that was the first time I
heard about saltine so I pitched that
story to this historian who then had the
the gumption to suggest that I go off
and I would learn more about life in the
world and writing going off and and
working as an undercover union organizer
and then writing about it than I would
ever learn as his assistant at the time
I could not have been more angry at him
because he sort of sent me on this
trajectory and in fact a few years later
I remember standing in the buffet of the
casino watching CNN and seeing this
historian talking about I think the Gulf
oil spill and kind of cursing his name
but I am forever grateful to Ted Conover
and Douglas Brinkley the historian who
set me off to do this because now I have
this book which I'm very proud of this
book all day
so this book I went down to Miami in
2010 after convincing the Union that I
could be a good salt salting is the act
of getting hired at a non-union
workplace and organizing it from the
inside we worked pretty diligently to
get hired at the targets the places the
union was targeting which your three
casinos and once inside I could start
making trouble and unionizing and the
the crux of our campaign was to get to
know our co-workers that was the most
important thing a salt could do and in
order to do that we would go on socials
because people are never really relaxed
at work enough to talk about themselves
and talk about what makes them tick and
we wanted to understand what made them
tick so we'd go on these socials and so
and then I would then kind of take that
information and I would share it with my
union organizer Alex who would
eventually go and convince this person
to join the unionization committee armed
with the kind of intelligence that I had
provided so that was yeah that was the
basic premise of salting and we'll pick
it up there I was working at the time in
the well I worked at two two casinos
three different jobs I worked in the
twin spires Tavern which was the
high-end restaurant in the casino I
worked in the buffet as a waiter
fetching Arnold Palmer's and I worked as
a bartender at another casino but we'll
start there Alex my organizer continued
to push me to make friends in the buffet
on slow nights I would visit the buffet
to get to know the servers this required
me to walk through the dish room which
connected the tavern to the buffet the
industrial dishwashing machine sounded
like a jet engine to keep the noise out
key on a hip hop poet Stuart steward I
had met at orientation would wear
headphones and sing along while he
scrubbed heard that she [ __ ] LeBron
but [ __ ] I don't know when John Mike
DeStefano or Stanley Donovan the three
managers walked through the dish room
key on would switch to Negro spirituals
wade in the water wade in the water
children he said it was the quickest way
to get white managers out Erica had told
me that kion had been in trouble with
the law a few times but hoped a steady
job would keep him on the straight and
narrow sessi a stout Peruvian woman in
her late 50s worked next to key on her
pastel eyeshadow applied liberally said
more about her exuberant personality
than her all-white uniform after
receiving a say Patrick's Day card I
sent her in order to get her address
from her says he proceeded to give me
cards on Easter my birthday Thanksgiving
and Christmas
next to ceci Janette scrubbed the large
heavy cookware Jeannette was Haitian and
about the same age excessive ceci she
had five adult trilled children three
married and two college-age despite the
fact that she had lived in the United
States for 30 years Jeanette didn't
speak much English
neither did ceci they both understood
English though during orientation Haiti
was hit by a massive earthquake that
killed some 230,000 people months later
I asked Jeannette about her family in
Haiti I know three family died she said
two children in one school one cousin at
home bad bad bad says he said ceci and
Jeanette didn't talk to each other much
ceci told me this was because they
didn't get along not the language
barrier but despite but despite personal
differences there was a sense of
solidarity in the dish room both women
were ripped latex gloves that did little
to prevent their fingers from pruning
within the first hour of work they
looked out for each other
whenever one of them snuck a plate of
food or sat down while on the job they
helped each other lift heavy pots and
laughed together when Stanley Donovan
the head of the food and beverage
department walked through the dish room
wearing sneakers with curved platforms
meant to exercise and tighten his gluts
Alex had told me Alex my organizer had
told me to ask any older Haitian or
Latino women to take me to church he
called it a slam dunk social so I asked
ceci she understood what I was asking
but she couldn't respond fully in
English you right call I wrote my name
and a phone number on a piece of receipt
paper and she stuffed it into her bra
later that night I was as I was getting
off my shift I got a call from an
unfamiliar number is this James a young
woman asked in a perfect in in perfect
English my name is Daniela and my mother
tells me that you'd like to come to
church with us we are-- we arranged to
meet that Sunday on Mother's Day for
Mother's Day mass slam dunk indeed with
Alex pushing me I had no choice but to
hunt for socials like a college freshman
looking for a party Alex were checking
after my shifts did you get a social no
why not because Taylor said she was busy
this weekend dude you know that's not an
excuse these conversations with Alex
were brutal I started bombarding my
co-workers with requests to hang out
just to get Alex off of my back throw
enough lures in the water and something
is going to bite socials started filling
my schedule I went to dive bars Hooters
and a Jamaican Jerk joint I went to the
batting cages bowling and a baby shower
I had coffee with Ivan a bartender from
Slovenia who at some point or another
had worked at every hotel between Miami
and Fort Lauderdale wanting to avoid the
line at the popular strip club King of
Diamonds where strippers were scheduled
to box each other I went to a dingy
strip club next door with a group of
cocktail waitresses
we were accompanied by a casino VIP who
handed out stacks of $1 bills Jean
Louise a cook taught me to make griot a
Haitian dish made from pork shoulder
while I was cutting up pepper thyme and
garlic to add to the griot I learned
that Jean Louise had left her
drug-addicted husband when she was
pregnant with her second child as one of
the only female cooks she wasn't so much
offended by the misogyny in the casino's
kitchen but she was tired of it
gene Louise dreamed of becoming a
full-time caterer but even at 13 75 an
hour one of the highest
food-and-beverage wages at the casino
she wasn't saving enough to realize that
dream I went to one gay club with the
slot attendant named Sam and another
with Rodney who was a caged cashier I
managed to sashay around the dance floor
while prudish Lea avoiding close contact
I learned that Sam the slot attendant
had lucky you tattooed above his nether
region I also learned that he made 1150
an hour when he worked at the aisle the
unionized casino at our casino he made
$8 an hour
Lucia took me to a religious ceremony
based on Nichiren Buddhism at a new-age
retreat center in a posh suburb I
chanted alongside her my oho Renji kayo
ho been pwned I me driving to and from
the retreat centre
Lucia talked about her ex-husband who
had gambled away their savings playing
pool she also told me that in addition
to the $9 an hour she was making at the
casino she got by with $600 a week she
made cleaning the mansion of a cookware
tycoon in Aventura but when the pay was
cut to $360
she couldn't manage her home loan
modification payment her credit card
debt and the money she needed to send to
her sick father in Uruguay Lucia was
considered was considering taking
another job as a maid in West Palm Beach
in order to tutor a cocktail waitress
Patricia in algebra I spent an hour
refreshing
skills I went gambling at Mardi Gras
Hard Rock and Gulf Stream I spent an
afternoon doing sit-ups and push-ups
with Chris a slot attendant an amateur
boxer I was sore for weeks
ceci the Peruvian dishwasher took me to
Mother's Day Mass with her it was in
Spanish and when the priest asked all
the mothers to stand
I also stood up everyone in our pew
laughed at me and afterward we ate skirt
steak and Papa a la huancaina at sissy's
friend's house I got to know sissy's
diabetic daughter Daniela she was only
13 but talked to me with the honesty and
thoughtfulness of someone much older I
want to be a doctor she told me while
driving from church to lunch my father
died a year ago and since I have
diabetes I want to learn to help people
even when co-workers didn't open up and
gush about their personal lives socials
forced a familiarity that fostered
comfort and confidence I realized just
how much ceci trusted me when she called
called me as she was leaving work one
day she was hysterical gasping to use
the little English she knew you come get
me she was waiting for me when I pulled
up alongside the casinos loading dock
she was crying she gave me an address in
South Miami and explained that we needed
to go get Daniela 45 minutes later we
pulled up to the house ceci went inside
a minute later a man exited the house
carrying Daniela and arranged her in the
back seat of my car
ceci followed yelling at the man who had
carried Daniela out Daniella's eyes were
rolling into the back of her head and
she was heaving and shaking when I asked
Daniela what was wrong she didn't
respond to me ceci got in the car go
Hospital I drove one block pulled over
and called an ambulance Daniela had gone
into diabetic shock when the paramedics
arrived they rushed her into the back
of the ambulance and ceci went to the
hospital with her Daniela was in the
hospital for days I still don't know
exactly what happened that afternoon why
the people inside the house hadn't
called an ambulance themselves I visited
Danielle and ceci in the hospital
Daniela translated for her mother my
mother wants to thank you for saving my
life
even if Daniela had been on the brink I
didn't save her life when says he called
me I didn't know the gravity of the
situation I almost told her that I was
busy when in fact I was lying on my
couch reading a book enjoying my day off
the only reason I hadn't was because I
knew says her family had welcomed me and
our socials had created a bond strong
enough for ceci to trust me in a dire
situation some might argue that our
relationship was built on a falsehood
but I knew early on that CeCe's vote
didn't mean much she wasn't a leader in
the dishwashing room though the origins
of our friendship may have been
calculated it was an honest friendship
so at some point I switched to from one
casino to another and started salting at
a new casino called Mardi Gras and it
was a strategic decision but I am going
to just read a quick excerpt here from
the first day at Mardi Gras casino to
give you a sense of the casino life my
first shift at Mardi Gras was on Tuesday
September 6 2011 guests that day could
get their pictures taken with a tiger in
the lobby Lions a zebra and monkeys were
all scheduled to make appearances in the
coming weeks the casinos concept lays a
label Tom rouler was refreshing in the
spirit I was given a glittery pumpkin
orange vest to wear over a black uniform
I looked like a magician at an 80s Bat
Mitzvah
I arrived 10 minutes early for every
shift in Mardi Gras I would enter
through the employee entrance clock in
and get a walkie-talkie from Bobbie a
geriatric security guard with a
Christmas white beard he usually
listened to an oldies station that
played songs with beachy harmonies I
would press a blue exit button to the
right of the door and proceed onto the
casino floor immediately and immediately
I would feel the machines around me
exploding quaking blinking ding ding
ding ding bling after a few seconds the
commotion receded into my subconscious
like traffic on a New York Street they
were the same machines that cluttered
the floor at Calder velasca sino had
worked at the customers were the same -
some came to mardi gras because they
were tired of kaulder others bounced
around from one casino to another they
had the same foggy stares on weekends
pass East us female samba dancers
adorned with a preponderance of plumage
we parade through the casino some guests
seemed to like the entertainment but
boasts never looked away from their slot
machines the walk to the money room was
short I would swipe my badge and enter
the first of two man traps there was
always a moment of claustrophobia as I
couldn't you I couldn't open the next
door in the sequence until the door
behind me had locked sometimes someone
in surveillance would chirp through the
radio one second someone's coming
through that meant I had to wait for
someone on the other side of the door I
was always under surveillance it only
took a couple of shifts to get over that
I had nothing to hide
inside the money room an attendant
wearing a pocket list and me a clear
plastic bag through a window it had $300
in it the cashier tellers were given
much bigger bags containing at least
$20,000 they would flip their hands
periodically to show the cameras they
weren't hiding any money the quick gist
gesticulation looked like something my
pop-up would do while describing good
but not great spaghetti after counting
my bag
I would radio surveillance
Sierra one this is James Walsh going
from mr1 to the main bar because I was
the newest bartender I was given a lot
of afternoon shifts that rarely had much
business those shifts were a great
opportunity to talk with cocktail
waitresses I'm not sure if the job made
them tough for if tough people were
attracted to the job but cocktail
waitresses were always the grittiest
savviest people in the building
I may have graped about life in the
buffet but after one shift as a cocktail
waitress I would have begged for crab
night and Arnold Palmer refills their
entire shifts six to eight hours were
spent walking which was fine for
sprightly 20-somethings but brutal for
the older waitresses they also endured
some of the most degrading treatment
from customers there were regular Joe's
who believed the cocktail waitresses
uniforms was uniform was an infant
invitation to complement her appearance
or worse there are people who snapped
their fingers for service or clapped
their hands or whistled there were
drunks creeps and men too thick to know
when to shut up
there were loathsome customers who would
call the waitresses [ __ ] and [ __ ] most
of the time the women just took it on
the chin it was all part of the hustle
during one of my first shifts I worked
alongside two cocktail waitresses ELISA
and Lena ELISA couldn't have been older
than 25 petite a blonde American a
blonde Cuban American who lived in your
Magic City casino in Little Havana Lena
was 40 and as she liked to say she
looked good for her age she had dark
black hair that she pulled into a
ponytail tone pipe biceps and a faint
polish accent she was finishing a
graduate degree in interior design
I asked Lena how she could afford it she
dances at Scarlett's ELISA said
Scarlett's was a popular strip club
nearby
shut up Lena said she's joking I don't
actually dance at Scarlett's I just keep
working Lena used the floor like a
catwalk she walked with her shoulders
back stiff and upright her ponytail
swinging with each long stride
you took it was as if she knew she was
better than the customers she served and
that's probably why they tipped her so
well
Lina came to the United States when she
was 24 she'd earned a master's degree in
physical education in Poland but she
didn't speak a word of English she got
her first job as a waitress at Hooters
on Long Island by learning to recognize
interview questions and memorizing rote
responses
I want to make customer happy eventually
she moved to Florida where she and her
boyfriend opened a dirt bath dirt bike
track after her boyfriend was in a
life-threatening dirt bike accident Lina
was forced to close the course and nurse
him back to help it was really bad she
told me I had to clean him when he [ __ ]
himself then when he got his strength
back he started hitting her I told him
after I take care of you this is how you
treat me no way now she's with his
brother
ELISA chimed in shut up she's joking no
I'm not I'm single and happy after a few
shifts I started asking Leena about the
job often workers would brush off my
questions by saying this job was a
temporary stop between their past and
future Leena believed interior design
was her future she was ready to quit
mardi-gras as soon as she could support
herself as a full-time interior
decorator which made it hard to talk to
her about her current situation but when
I asked her about the head of the food &
beverage Department Sallie Lena lit up I
hadn't met Sally yet but I'd heard she
was I see the customer had complained
about Lena service most managers are
reasonable people who understand that
complaints often come from irritable
guests who mistake a waitress's busyness
for negligence or bartenders efficiency
for rudeness she calls me to her office
Lena said about Sally she points her
finger at me and she says you will not
talk until I talk to until I tell you to
talk if I didn't need this job I would
have told that [ __ ] off and walked out
it wasn't much but I made a note Lena
hates Sally I asked her about insurance
scheduling and seniority
there was a work issue car wash then I
asked about her paid time off you know
they only pay five dollars for vacation
pay what like you're earning tips on
vacation pay - I said I'd had a similar
problem with my vacation pay at the
other casino vacation time was doled out
in eight hour increments and I had been
paid as a tipped employee instead of
minimum wage I told my manager about it
and I got the full minimum wage 725 the
next time I used my paid time off in
Lena's case it could have been an honest
mistake by Mardi Gras but I figured that
in an industry that required employees
to flip their hands to show that they
weren't holding any money anything was
possible so I want to open it up to Q&A
but before I do that was just a taste of
the employee side of the story because
the other side of course is management
and and we saw quite a bit of resistance
from the casinos we were organizing in
South Florida right now thrive the
private industry for those of you don't
know is that just over six percent of
the workforce is unionized and what I
learned from observing the management
side was that the problem isn't that the
employees I worked with didn't want to
join the union it was simply that they
didn't have a chance to join the union
management had a toolbox of tactics to
delay and inhibit my co-workers or
prohibit my co-workers really from
joining the union and I hope that this
book is a reflection of the reality
which is we need to reconsider what it
takes to join a union in America and not
necessarily what the union represents
and that was sort of the conclusion I
came at as somebody who didn't grow up
knowing a lot about unions didn't grow
up in a union family so I hope you enjoy
it
it's a story about people not about
unions or casinos it's a really a story
about people and I hope you enjoy it
so can open up the question question is
did the Union know that you were
undercover writing a book when they sent
you undercover
it's a salt if you would like on Deep
Cover sure sure yes that's another
element of the story here that I also
write about was the fact that I didn't
tell the Union that I planned to write
this book so the Union was in the dark
about the book the casino is in the dark
about the Union and the book and and
that proposed a lot of challenges kind
of day one of journalism school 101 is
don't do something like this and you
know I set off day one out of journalism
school trying to do it and and it yeah
there were a lot of challenges and I'm
not necessarily sure I would I would do
it again because it is stressful
personally as well the Union augment
your pay testimony to send you into a
they send you into a non-union work sure
so so to answer that question saltine
there's a very long history of salt in
this practice of going in non-union
workshop it's been around as as long as
organized labor in the US and a lot of
different unions do it management knows
about it and some of them some unions
pay too they kind of pay the difference
between a salary exactly and but all the
salts I worked with in Florida were
volunteer they were young recent college
grads who are activists and kind of
looking for a way to work their way into
the labor movement
yes we're the salting activities that
they did you differentiate between
documented and undocumented workers that
would be interesting projects in South
Florida I worked at casinos which
require a state background check you get
a slot license so I'm not really as far
as I know I didn't work with anybody who
was undocumented I think there are
probably ways to get around the BAC
background checks but I did not I know
that some organizers even when we were
talking about workers who were
documented especially from Haiti were
often hesitant to talk to the Union to
draw attention to their family who might
also have undocumented workers
personally so I like I said I didn't
know anything about unions or the labor
movement going into this really and I
you know like I said it's the challenge
is is is is not necessarily convincing
my co-workers that the Union is a good
thing the challenge is much bigger than
that
for example I don't know people are
familiar with the term right-to-work 26
states now in the US are right-to-work
which means unions represent an entire
workplace regardless of whether or not
the workers at that word workplace are
paying dues so unions like to say right
to freeload and it's really it sounds
nice right right to work it's this
Orwell Orwellian language but it's it's
more about destroying unions is what I
found so I had a conversation with a
co-worker who she literally said to me
listen James
she was this great waitress who loved to
kind of like look after me and she said
listen James as soon as she found out
the union was knocking on doors the
union is a good thing
but don't join because you don't have to
you don't have to pay dues and you can't
blame somebody I think she was she was
in tipped employee so she was making
something like 425 an hour plus tips she
had a bunch of kids
you can't blame somebody for not wanting
to pay dues when you're making that that
little it's the difference between you
know a tank of gas but it's it's so
important so this is somebody who's
flat-out telling me that the union is
something that she would want but joint
you know didn't want to join it's much
higher than that you know it's it's it's
it goes the right-to-work laws so the
fight is just as much in the supreme
court as we see now as it is on the
casino floor
yes so thank you incredible work
so a lot of what you what you read
really is about it seems to be about the
misogyny about the women you were
working with
I'm sure there's you know you mentioned
the guy who sings wade in the water and
then you know the other song but so how
much of you know how much of this time
and casino's how much of your time union
organizing how much in unions you know
is there this sort of you know it seems
like there are a lot of women involved
and a lot of women who are we meeting
who are needing way more money to take
care of their family take care of their
sick children you know number one how
were you able to gain I mean you
explained how you're able to gain their
trust but you know you're you're not
you're not them right you're not from
their background so how are you able to
do that number one and number two I
guess what can we how can we learn and
how can we think more deeply about women
alone in this position and is that how
important is that compared to a it's not
important compared to men but I mean how
much of it is sort of women dominated is
what you read tonight is very much about
the woman experience and you're sort of
absorption of that yeah that's not a
clear question no no I mean it's it's
that you don't even know how relevant
you are because or maybe you do women
are much more likely to they are you
know one of the number one factors and
whether or not a union campaign is
successful women are much more likely
it's particularly women of color and I
saw that at the casino ii casino i
worked at we organized this Leadership
Committee of 15 workers and let's see 12
of the 15 leaders were women all of them
were women of color so I think a lot of
union organizers would say that these
attacks on unions right now are also
attacks on women of color and as far as
me personally yeah I don't know so
somebody once pointed out to me that the
first social that I went on was like a
white college kid right it was easiest
for me it was like
I'm gonna hang out with this guy because
it's what we can talk about you know
baseball and I learned different ways to
approach these women and not go after
but to be closer to women who never
explicitly asked I think it was more
like my organizers knew that that's how
it would end up you know yeah they want
me to get it talk to as many people as
op as possible
I remember one organizer once said to me
yeah I mean we are going to win the
housekeeping department because the
housekeeping department was 98% Haitian
and he said these people have been
through so much to get here and left so
much behind that they are not scared of
Management and I think again all twelve
people on the Union Committee the
Leadership Committee we're also where
Haitian as well yeah when you are
talking to people on the entry level
people and you're making the case for
the Union is it a left-right political
discussion you're having or is it
dollars and cents that's another really
something that I learned there's no way
to know if somebody's Pro Union based on
left-right gender anything you know it's
and it's not even dollars and cents of
course when you're making 725 an hour
nine dollars an hour ten dollars an hour
it's going to be about dollars and cents
to some point some extent but what I
heard from my co-workers over and over
it was about respect in the workplace
that they wanted to gain some measure of
power in the workplace because they were
sick and tired of feeling like any day
could be their last day at work and that
was part of the pitch that we would give
on house visits workers were scared and
rightly so as I learned that they would
get fired if they were part of this
union organizing committee management
would
and our pitch was okay so they they
might fire you that's that is definitely
a risk you have to take but who said
who's to say they're not going to fire
you tomorrow when you accidentally take
your break you know your break runs two
minutes long or when you're you know for
any any reason they could be fired
so it white black Republican Democrat
you know there was no way to know and
organizers really understand that when
they knock on somebody's door even even
going so far as to say whether they say
their pro-union or not that doesn't even
matter if the pro-union or not because
oftentimes as I found out they didn't
know anything about the Union right I
had one co-worker asked me if management
was going to organize the union for us I
had another co-worker ask if we were
already in the Union so there's no
really baseline you know it's all you
know it's all a blank sheet as far as
organizers are concerned yes I I would
say I'll answer it but you could also
buy the book we the first casino I
worked at was unionized but that was
after I left the second casino I worked
at it has not been unionized and that's
all I'll say but yeah we had no shot of
being unionized because it was such a
brutal anti-union campaign it was called
the Union was called unite here that
unite here that they are Hotel and
Casino what if anything did you learn
negative about the unions and their
tactics during this cuz you're obviously
coming in with a perspective but did you
see anything on the other side then
that's a very good question
I know as far as what I witnessed
firsthand there are a lot of difficult
decisions to be made
you know in a campaign as to how much do
I have to put these workers at risk
right if I know that this is something
an action that might get them fired am I
going to back down or am I going to have
the workers bear this risk and and that
when workers were fired
you know the Union did their best to try
to find them jobs and counsel them one
thing that I really left a bad taste in
my mouth
we so I've give away a little bit we
eventually there were a lot of workers
that were fired and we went to the
National Labor Relations Board that then
files filed charges against the casino I
was shocked when two prominent unions
filed notices on behalf of management
without even contacting the Union I was
working with saying that we've worked
with this manager the president of the
casino at different casinos that they
run around the country and have never
witnessed any kind of anti-union tactic
so if there were two union leaders
blindly writing letters on behalf of
management without contacting and
hearing the workers side of the story
which I thought was kind of shocking and
I don't know if that happened I'm not a
labor historian if that happened in days
of old but it was shocking to me
of course oh yeah different tactics that
the management you used to prevent
unionization we told something about
that short yes
well the it's kind of a tiered process
and how many tiers how far will
management go and on the first basic
level they'll host these group meetings
so we had management come to the buffet
and they would come to the buffet and
organize have all the workers come
together and just kind of act like it
was a normal meeting you know say how do
you guys like what's going on here are
you taking advantage of the 401k that we
offer and no nobody was taking advantage
the 401k because they didn't have enough
money left at the end of the month do
you take advantage of the 401k I think
actually when there's one meeting at
which one manager raise his hand for the
401k question and then they would do a
few things they would say so we hear the
unions knocking on your door well unions
as you might know I have an important
place in American history there's all
about history you know child labor laws
minimum wage so and then they just list
all these things that unions have done
and aren't you glad we already have all
those things like aren't you glad the
federal government takes care of US
workers and they would say the Union is
driving a wedge all unions do right now
is drive a wedge between workers and
management because they don't have
anything to sell the federal government
already provides all these things so
they're bit all there are businesspeople
trying to get your money and then they
would go so far one Human Resources
employee recommended that we call the
police if a union organizer come because
these people are just like stalkers then
it's say the word stalkers and I
remember talking to one co-worker after
that who said
you know well yeah I mean this is
Florida you should you never know if
somebody's knocking on your door if
they're coming to kill you you know and
they just can't it's a you live in
Florida it's not like a great leap of
the imagination and so that would be the
start of it and that these are a lot of
these really just toad that toe the line
with legality whether or not they're
gonna offer disincentives or incentives
to not join the union and and then go so
far as to fire employees and in
workplaces like the service industry
firing an employee finding a reason to
fire employee is pretty easy so you can
hide behind that it's illegal to fire
somebody for union activity but it's not
illegal to fire somebody for a cocktail
waitress for loitering which is I
believe the job description of a
cocktail waitress or you know yeah
there's there's there's a host of ways
to hide behind that I wondered about
that your strategy to go undercover as a
reporter to do this story would you did
you think that that worked out for you
and would you do that again so yeah I
kind of look at undercover reporting I
mean it's a privilege right you can't
you still have to try to bring some
objectivity you there's no there's
nothing I there's something happens in
this book that I feel I set on that path
because it would make a great story I
don't want to bait people into good
quotes I mean that's that's basic
journalism whether or not your honor
whether you're undercover or not you
know I want these quotes to be genuine
reflections of the people in the book
and I think I certainly think yes I was
successful in writing the story this
story of salting that hasn't been
written about and writing this story of
service workers trying to organize from
the inside whether or not I would do it
again I I just I don't know
it's difficult because in some ways
salting is like reporting because you're
getting to know people and getting them
to talk and that's great but getting to
know people without them knowing that
you're going to write about them doesn't
kind of feel great at the other end so
that's something you know I'm still kind
of unpacking and dealing with yeah good
question
the first person so salt salting like I
said has been going on forever the first
person to actually call up salting I
believe was the president of the
Electrical Workers in the late 1800s and
he borrowed the phrase from the term
salting a mine which was a kind of
skeezy way of making a mine looked a lot
more valuable by sprinkling gold around
before you sell the mine the connection
there I'm not really sure and that
actually goes even further back because
salting comes from salting wells
you know freshwater wells were more
common than salt wells which I didn't
even know it was a thing assault well as
you move further west so people would
just dump a bunch of salt in and be like
hey is his assault well and sell it you
know sell it off how that connects to
the practice of salting you'd have to
ask Henry Miller who the electrical
workers he was the president of the
Electrical Workers Union the late 1800s
and I believe the electrical workers say
that to the day he died he was working
as a salt in non-union casinos or
non-union not casinos workplaces yeah do
you meet did you need to get people's
permission to write about them how does
that work out don't you need to do that
no I mean we really read it closely and
change names and identifying
characteristics so that is not required
which of course goes hand-in-hand with
why it's it's a difficult
yeah a difficult dance then read the
book because I'm sure you had I don't
know I really don't know since I mean
since you're being very specific about
where you are working and the
characteristics on the department
wouldn't there be consequences for those
individuals now well that's why I've
protected identities you know we've made
sure that a lot of these so one thing
that's that played to my favor and just
that is the turnover rate in the service
industry many of these workers are long
gone yeah what are the people you work
with think about the government and how
it it might have protected them or not
protecting them I mean Horizonte towards
government and today these people may be
a part in the minority people would any
of these people be voting through Donald
Trump today
yeah that's another really good question
well terms of the government that was
sort of a rollercoaster because as
co-workers were fired and the cases were
filed with the National Labor Relations
Board there was this sense of okay we're
out we're gonna go get justice we're
gonna get them to hire us back and get
back pay and just a few months these
people were fired in November 2011 the
court case happened in June 2012 and
just a few months later the judge ruled
that they had been wrongfully fired and
should be put back to work with back pay
so you think that's great that is swift
justice relatively swift justice under a
year these people can go back to work
and still today that case is being
appealed some people were offered their
jobs back others weren't there are just
so many ways to delay delay delay and I
watched my co-workers you know anytime
there was news about the case at first
they believed that there had been some
sort of justice and it just just waned
you know that just faded and relying on
the government to carry that out yeah it
just faded and whether or not some of
them would vote for Donald Trump that's
interesting if you look at it varies so
much from Union to Union
I think Donald Trump has found some
support among union members and I think
there have been a few polls that show a
strong support but just look at the
Union endorsements they are for Bernie
Sanders
sure
oh just people I worked with in general
hi I find it hard to believe now I don't
think I don't think many of my
co-workers would have been on the Donald
Trump wagon many of them liked it yeah
as I've told you were women and women of
color people Donald doesn't really pull
well with so it would be an anomaly I
think yeah what was your overall
impression you took away on the future
organized labor it seems like these big
Koch brother kind of funding efforts to
break unions and seeing it at the sort
of ground level what do you think the
what's your impression of the future
well you said it the Koch brother or
whatever dark money funding campaigns to
change States to right-to-work and
various other insidious ways that cases
have gone before the Supreme Court that
affect the workplace I worked at a
really really effective and if you look
at the numbers they are not good if
somebody who told you 10 years ago that
that Michigan would have gone you know
right to work Detroit Auto Workers the
home of the Auto Workers would have gone
right to work you would have been blown
away if somebody told you that West
Virginia home coalminers the home of the
Maharani you know labor movement they've
gone right to work it would have been
hard to believe and that's happening
right now you know down to 6% and losing
ground every year that being said the
organizers I met were extremely good at
what they did and they were doing it for
the right reasons I can tell you they
were passionate they were working at all
hours and they were doing it in a smart
way
and the local in South Florida has
more members now than it did five years
ago and I know that's because of the
progress those organizers are making and
I think that for a long time the service
industry sort of felt like this square
peg in a round hole because of the
turnover because of the kind of solitary
nature of the work and I I think that
maybe people are realizing that you look
at the fight for 15 the campaign to
change the minimum wage to $15 that's
been a union funded campaign so if
there's any other kind of harbinger of
things to come
I think unions are still successful in
what they do I don't I know that's not a
great yes-or-no answer you know I know
that may be satisfying but there's so
much in the air I know did you advise
any of the people who are in the book
prior to publication albeit under
different names that you were doing this
for sure I did yes and I got a mixed I
got a mixed response the union is not
thrilled about the fact that I'm writing
about saltine and this is despite the
fact that every major company you know
not only knows about saltine but has
ways to actively look for salt and
spends a lot of money to do that but I
understand they didn't want the Union is
at a point where they really want to
take care of their messaging and this
was not vetted by the Union in any way
and other people were excited about it
within the Union to have this story told
so it was a mixed response
yeah just just a couple more questions
okay if we have any more no all right oh
sure yes Kaleo so yes Kalia was this so
it's very hard to find it's a lot harder
than you think to find the leader that
you want to join your committee because
too often you get caught up in oh this
person has a lot of people congregated
around them all the time but that's
because they're funny it's not because
they're this person is a leader or this
person is you know really nurturing but
maybe it's because you know he he's a
great dad not necessarily because he's a
leader
I knew Kalia was a leader because she is
somebody who her father was a drug
dealer who had been killed her mother
was a drug addict and she had grown up
taking care of her little brother moving
him around the country
and so she was tough right
and then she one day at work she had you
know a lot of people around her who
looked up to her and one day at work we
had to do at the buffet we had to clean
down the tables and then have management
come over and sign off and say yes this
person's table is clean and I of course
never did that and as like the one white
guy always got away with just being like
yep my table is good I'm just gonna
leave but they still had to you know
have people sign off and the manager
gave her a really hard time about
cleaning off this table and she just
said you know what
Randy why are you giving me a hard time
right now and Randy the manager just
kind of like shriveled and said if you
want to push back come to my office and
we could have this conversation and
Kalia said nope I'm gonna do it right
here in front of all my co-workers where
I have witnesses and Randy just walked
away and that was the last time Randy
ever pushed Clea around so I knew she
was definitely a leader we wanted and
she when I left the first casino I
worked at it was the hardest for me to
like say goodbye to her because she was
the first person on our committee
she stayed through
you know a full year of work and she was
kind of disappointed because I think she
saw me as sort of this Patriot in the
buffet despite the fact that she didn't
know I was working with the Union so I
heard that yes she was eventually fired
because she accrued too many small
little write-ups which is another way to
get workers and get this turnover so I
heard that she was fired but I you know
I think it's time that I send her a copy
of the book and see what yeah yeah as
you're describing this it strikes me
that how long will you do this two years
the dumbest woman oh crazily lonely two
years where no one around you got to
know like what you were doing while you
were doing it who you were what you
represented and when you talked about
kind of doing it again is that on a
personal level is that not a huge
personal sacrifice that like is that for
you worth it because that sounds really
sad I wouldn't describe it as lonely
it's more like having a secret because I
wasn't undercover in the sense that I
was always myself I didn't have some
other identity 99.9% of my conversations
weren't about the Union or anything they
were just hanging out with friends and
getting to know friends
so of course carrying that secret is
exhausting
and can take its toll but there's no
part of me that felt lonely plus it was
in Miami so people were visiting all the
time so I had friends that were always
coming to visit but I genuinely liked my
co-workers and the other organizers I
was working with and could be myself in
front of them in just about every way
except for the whole journalism thing so
thank you so much
[Applause]
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly author interview program former
Bush administration official John you
argued that executive power has gone
beyond its constitutional limits under
President Obama Michael Eric Dyson
explored how race has impacted the Obama
administration in Washington Post
columnist EJ Dionne
argued that the Republican Party's
adoption of senator Barry Goldwater's
conservative principles is driving away
moderate voters